how's Dom France Marty ah welcome back
to postal to you brothers really wanted
more of this so we're gonna keep playing
some more oh my god it's my favorite
year one side what did you see
oh you know what let's just enjoy
ourselves in the pool with somebody who
you know Jesus Christ it's possessed my
navel juice is repellent to the water
our navels are connected I never felt
this empowered as a woman alright so
we're gonna head out we had a lot of
stuff to do get toilet paper deliver
mother whatever the [ __ ] wrecked the
competition no problem for some navel
juice lovers and we're right Thank You
Vicky can make a tea kitty kitty I will
not hurt you kitty kitty career okay I'm
well pissed now
Oh take this kitty
ah here we are the White House ah my
favorite because no no no no [ __ ] you
[ __ ] off do you want me to [ __ ]
murder you
now you pissed me off that's what I'm
gonna do leave it it is safe it is baby
baby baby get it baby
nothing about size let's keep it excused
gonna ban you and we gotta burn you here
we go wow that's just too bad isn't it
[Music]
looks like it's gonna rain for a while
oh no Derek what happened to you
it's pants have my navel juice able to
release the pain hi there friend
holy [ __ ]
and he kicks the bodies goes how am I
gonna get the toilet paper now when I
hit through that employees only door and
help yourself was talking dismembering
this gentleman oh [ __ ] okay well that's
what happens when you have Taco Tuesday
there we go where is it there it is we
got it we got the paper roll mission
accomplished
so next thing would be to deliver the
motherboards all right I can do it
hey doggy ah hi doggy you don't look too
nice oh god I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
you want something to play with I get
you something to play with doggy place
Hills place challenge place oh thank you
doggy look what I find for you take it
yes I could play with the hand good
doggy good doggy good doggy
yes all right go get it go get it boy
stupid little [ __ ] cuties are you
kidding yes I'll be jealous dog it's not
personal
[Music]
kidding Pizza back together forever shut
up you [ __ ]
don't say that kitty you raised this
[ __ ] okay let's go in to deliver the
motherboards I am also very excited
about it kitty
all right we're at the gay market I love
video games some people say video games
constant violence oh no I'm so sorry man
I didn't mean it Oh Josie cute legs
chase tell staysail the navel juice will
save you you drop your butt your drop
your rocket launcher man you forgot
[Music]
okay let's install the motherboard oh we
gotta guess the lean girl gasoline what
gasoline girl gonna do what I gotta pee
on her face take it you love it now I
will take your legs we're not accepting
the neighbors
[Music]
those are the rules
almost there kitty we're almost there
stop please do not shoot kick set fire
to or urinate on equipment table juice
without this problem hundred percent one
percent I can't like a million computers
for the server's
oh that's right we gotta get in there
man oh I will have to take your legs for
this that is some nice [ __ ] twerking
magic sorry the legs legs are mine my
leg Cyrus
[Music]
that's my count
and what the [ __ ] are you ah fathom see
nothin hint ha ha we are triumphing over
two zombie oppressor Vince in his clan
and who do we have here
uh don't mind me I'm just passing
through holy dude
Vince's second-in-command you're the
tyrant who has permeated so many of our
kind in what my ass 11 years ago with my
minions take your prison hoops we have
some unfinished business to take care of
you're gonna be spending the night in
the junkyard
okay damn it we could have chaired that
episode of that bris
I hope you enjoyed it leave a like if
you want more and leave a comment about
Kitty and how well you want kitty to be
in the future and I will see you bros in
the next one as always stay awesome
brush ma'am come back at once are you
gonna offer [ __ ] sake none of my show